bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che sono
video sono farisei oggi siamo su qui
ok questo videogame che ti permette di
disegnare cose in 20 secondi devi
segnare queste cose in modo tale da far
indovinare la tizia che tenta ad
indovinare queste cose quindi io 20
secondi per disegnare una roba la prima
cosa di oggi ragazzi e di yoga yoga
serio come cazzo fosse disegnarlo yoga a
esista la dolce un tizio ma che lollipop
un attimo come cazzo affatto indovina il
diving board cos'è diving board fermin
attimo diving board sarebbe trampolino
no non va bene
aspetta questa piscina perfetto non
poteva essere altro da golf club mazza
da baseball di mine aspetta ice ibleo
ecco dai facilissimo porca [ __ ] fatto
anche le strisce madonna un fenomeno
roller skate roller skate va bene mica
fatto è difficile fare un roller skate
ora che bravo ora che bravo che schifo
orecchio
ok ai siti web cosa è un pezzetto di
fatto li faccio rifaccio ai simac a
questo vecchio tipo hai messo la faccia
questa è la faccia dai ci vede che un
orecchio [ __ ] l'altro oltre a questo
porco demonio e ai conti a sé una che va
beh lasciamo perdere beemer ang
si no e che cazzo poteva essere sono un
boomerang e questa roba spiega mica nei
ragazzi cane guarda che bel cane chi ti
faccio ice il washington ma sei scema ma
tu sei uno stupido nata a port che
attraversano indovina vicane che aveva
anche l'occhio guercio tipo guè pequeno
allora amica via nei dominate cinque su
sei e non mi hai azzeccato orecchio qual
è il tuo problema questo è un orecchio
si vede possiamo subito questo
capolavoro su twitter per vedere ai
vostri le vostre reaction in diretta
perché sono contentissimo di condividere
con voi queste opere d'arte meravigliose
per favore non toccare aiutateci a
preservare l'arte che effettivamente il
boom era anche un po storto ma ok guarda
zia quando hai mai visto un boomerang
dritto fammelo sapere stai migliorando
sono fiera di te grazie zia grazie al
sole firmo tutte le vendiamo su ebay gli
avanti ragazzi play again è visto che
avete apprezzato i miei primi disegno a
precedente anche i secondi and see credo
di aver cielo sembra un più la mano di
alien però va bene blackberry porca è ma
come cazzo faccio disegnare un
blackberry
quanto qualche disgraziato il tuo
telefono o [ __ ] quartiere macello il
blackberry zio mi capita tastiera
schermino al nocciolo guardare è un the
blackberry porco due passi più cachet ma
è il blackberry scusami anche che si
intendeva con blackberry quanto era un
blackberry quello che ho fatto ma
[ __ ] non essendovi non blackberry
o cosa ski blackberry mosquito
[Musica]
candeliere candela ball candeli erbe
candeliere no non ci ho capito eh la
madonna quanto brutto ci provo questo
sia sia porca [ __ ] dishwasher
lavastoviglie lavastoviglie potuta
quadrata quale ti aspetta aspetta che
doveva dentro il capolavoro ma spetta a
mykonos porta a eva qualcuno non so
disegnare gli impianti piatti non so
disegnare ragazzi sono andato nel panico
c'è questo problema io nel disegno
quando non so disegnare lavavano nel
panico sun il sole lo so fare qualche
bravo hai siseco minchia quanto pratico
fatto da bambino perfetto la questura
billy black berry santo di dio cioè solo
blackberry non hai azzeccato come è
giocato dishwasher aspettano la cabina
ma la zecca tornò dishwasher l'ha preso
ha indovinato dishwasher come cazzo ha
esaminato lavastoviglie
no non ci posso credere che indovinato
lavastoviglie non ho capito questa mia
indovinato lavastoviglie così e non mi
ha indovinato blackberry ma questa è
scema vuoi vedere cosa ne pensano
veramente questa volta questa la voglio
vedere ho capito la lavastoviglie perché
è vera arte è effettivamente molto
astratta che infame non capisco l'arte
neanch'io perché ha un occhio sono però
fatto in tempo a fare l'altro zia penso
di non aver mai visto nei disegni così
belli mosquito eh vabbè sempre più
appagante questo videogioco hot air
balloon
mongolfiera chiunque ragazzi finché non
arriviamo a 6 su 6 fotte cazzi
mongolfiera veloce che è sì square
mamma mia che mongolfiera porta è ma
porca airplane tutte le roba aeree
positivo quanto è bello sto aereo
mamma mia che bella aereo oceano oceano
erano due rivera in a2 oceano perfetto
fan fame devo disegnare quelli che
chiedono gli autografi o quello che fa
l'aria che sarebbe ventilatore 1
shuriken certo perché se faccio parte il
gigante sto cazzo di ventilatore è il
ventilatore di sheen cecchino chio jim
brower faccio tutto un fiore tutto
petalo zoe così ma hai dei problemi
mentali zia naso naso bravo bravo porca
eva bravo sei su sei cazzo nuovo
contatto ero troppo preso dal disegno
bellissimo quindi la fa ti sei su sei
che sia ragazzi complimenti ventilatore
secondo me è quello che merita in questo
round andiamo a vedere subito che cosa
ne pensa la gente
credo che l'approvazione di putin in
questo momento se la cosa che più mi
appaga e di tutto il caso può
accompagnare solo bella l'ultima
all'aereo e bellissimo
l'ultima sembra il collo di una in
costume effettivamente lipstick in libia
e
lucida labbra o rossetto vabbè tanto
sono uguali aspetta aspetta poi manca
questo è un taglierino aspetta li
facciamo li facciamo i paesi clip si
vede che ho lipstick porca [ __ ] rai
anche se credo sia semplice stereo non
ne sono sicuro proprio iamoci allora one
aspetta aspetta concentrato stesso
cassette broccoli ma tu sei tutta scema
pace si vede che non stai anche lanterne
frate porcu 2 the great wall of china ma
cosa di fumai da uno stereo alla grande
muraglia cinese un attimo e il passo è
breve
strawberry guarda le parole che fisco
con bernie non te la cavi molto bene zia
però proviamo a vedere fragola mi
ricordavo che si dicesse strawberry
detta bravissima bravissima esatto
showell e la pala giusto quali minecraft
perfetto
ma porca eva sono indovinati facilissimo
e in gel angel cose cresce senza dubbio
riguarda perfetto ciamo che ha bisogno
una giorno rmm aleci attaccare calcio
aspetta si aspetta icy area coperta e
anche se ne fiducia collaborero grazie
rinoceronte mi chiama è difficilissimo
rinuncerò anche allora hai mica che come
ho fatto benissimo che sono fatto troppo
bene
perfetto mica sono i domini sei scema
che per affetto il miglior di noce
notifica abbia mai visto in tutta la mia
vita
brava brava era semplicissimo d'accordo
ragazzi io direi che può essere qui
episodi è stato alquanto strano però mi
piace questa cosa di chiedervi in
diretta che cosa ne pensate di questi
capolavori moderni grazie avermi dato il
vostro parere su queste opere d'arte che
vi ricordo verranno vendute su ebay
adesso mi impegnerò a firmarle tutte
quante spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
un clone episodio di quick calcolo del
mulhouse momento è un mi piace anche a
pace di facebook e comito trascrizione
signore si scatena ci davano prossimo
video prega ragazzi